تم اختبار الملكة يوم الأحد
وجاء الاختبار إيجابيًا وتم
إبلاغنا بعد ذلك بفترة وجيزة أه نحن
نفهم أن جلالتها تعاني
من أعراض شبيهة بالبرد الخفيف وفقًا
للقصر ولكنها تتوقع استمرار
الواجبات الخفيفة في ويندسور خلال الأسبوع المقبل
وهذا يعني بشكل فعال  اجتماعات افتراضية للعمل المكتبي ،
فهذا يعني أنها
تواصل العمل ، إنها بحالة جيدة بما يكفي
لمواصلة العمل ، لذا هناك إشارة إلى
أن القصر لا يبدو
قلقًا للغاية بشأن حالتها ،
لكنهم أضافوا أنها ستستمر في تلقي
العناية الطبية وستتبع جميع
الإرشادات المناسبة التي تقترح
أنها حاليًا في عزلة
وهي إرشادات اللغة الإنجليزية حاليًا
أخبرنا أيضًا من قبل مصدر ملكي أنه
تم تشخيص عدد من الحالات في
فريق قلعة وندسور مما يشير إلى
تفشي المرض داخل القلعة ربما
هذا هو المكان الذي التقطته فيه نحن نعلم أيضًا
أه أن  كان أمير ويلز الأمير
تشارلز قد رغب الأسبوع الماضي أيضًا في
كاميلا دوقة كورنوال
لقد التقيت تشارلز المرغوبة بالملكة ولكن
يبدو أن هناك
تفشيًا لرياح الرياح ، ويبدو أن هذا
هو سبب اصطياد الملكة لها